What ways can I support my hormones better since they are all low and now I'm having trouble losing weight I found a supplement powder called better hormones below is a list of ingredients would this be good to help with balancing hormones better to lose weight.
Or do you have any other recommendations?
Okay, so first we have to define this term right here called hormones. So we have lots of horrible in our body. You know, what are we talking about?
So, if a person has a cancer that could be horrible and related, i.e., breast cancer, i.e., prostate cancer, i.e., you know, ovary cancer, uterine cancer.
Should you be trying to get those normal levels of estrogen, progesterone, testosterone, elevated? Well, maybe, maybe not. Certainly that estrogen should not get estrogen elevated.
So I think when the to understand this question, I think the person is talking more about thyroid hormones.
So, if you have a history of breast cancer, you should not be doing things to raise estrogen levels typical.
Now let's look at the supplement vitamin D. Well, let's just find vitamin B6, fine, platythetic acid. It's vitamin B5. That's fine.
Chastory berry extract. Now, chastory berry extract can be helpful to that would be considered like an adeptogenic herb, help balance, hormones. I would say that's typically fine.
So, I would say that's fine. Help extract. That is not fine. You know, touch on that just a second. Milk whistle. That's good for your liver.
Elucero. This is an adeptogenic herb. That's just fine too. Ginger. Ginger is an anti-inflammatory stuff, really, hormone balance, but they put it in here to help pull, you know, decrease inflammation. That's fine.
Ashwagandha. That's an adeptogen. So, that's fine. So, this product is really what they have in here because they have the kelp in here. I think they're thinking about adeptogenic herbs plus supporting the thyroid, but I'm going to tell you in a second why you shouldn't use kelp.
And altheonine. Altheonine is not technically an adeptogen, but it's eaten a lot of adeptogens because it can help club the brain and decrease anxiety, which a lot of reasons why a person may want to be under the adeptogen.
So, remember, adeptogenic herbs are a classification of herbs that can help lower hormones when they're elevated and help increase hormones when they're low. And when I use that term, hormones, I'm not talking about estrogen and progesterone. I'm talking about your hormones that stimulate your hypothalamus, your tuteria, your geritals, and your thyroid.
So, really, when we talk about hormones, we should classify them into those really those two groups, more your sex hormones, which would be your progesterone, your estrogen, your testosterone, pregnant alone, and those hormones that involve reproduction and your reproductive system, and your hormones that involve more your energy system
and which has to do with your metabolism, and it does have to do with weight loss, which is your thyroid, your geritals, your pituitary, your hypothalamus, and all the hormones that are released by those organs.
You don't want to be using kelp nor iodine if you have any thoughts of thyroid dysfunction, which if a person has an inability to lose weight, difficulty losing weight, it's quite possible that they have thyroid dysfunction, which really you should take a step back from taking any supplements and get your thyroid tested.
So, in the lab section of the member site, you could do a thyroid profile or you could do the complete wellness panel, which I think is $122, which gives you a CBC, a complete metabolic panel and a complete thyroid panel.
So, it's pretty inexpensive to get a complete thyroid panel and a good picture of everything else at the same time, because we really want to look at your free T-4, total T-4, same with T-3, TSH, and TPO antibodies and thyroid antibodies to make sure there's not a possible those going on.
If you have low thyroid, you shouldn't really be taking kelp at all, because it's high and iodide, it will probably push you into a Hashimoto state.
Look at the section on Hashimoto's in the autoimmune corpse to help you understand why.
But otherwise, so I would use this supplement, if you're like, hey, I don't want to do a blood test, I don't have the money to do with a blood test, just use an adaptogen.
So we have multiple adaptogens, adaptive clear, would be a good adaptogen to use, that's one of our private label adaptogens, adaptogen R3 from, from premier research lab is another good adaptogen to support that really if you have a trouble to lose weight, you really want to look at the thyroid gland.
You probably don't need chast tree for, that's not really supporting the thyroid so much.
This is probably not the best mix for you for not being able to lose weight.
So if you do need more help with that, then feel free to schedule a time.
I can give you some indications on what you do, but do starting with that complete wellness test would be a good thing, because it has a tiny bit.
Also look at it a Dutch test where it gives you a cortisol balance, that will be a good thing to do too.